so Carl one thing I wanted to ask you
was if I'm a solo entrepreneur how would
I go about finding an engineer to help
me work on these projects finding an
engineer can come in a myriad of
different ways you know you can always
place an ad on something like Craigslist
there's the tried and true linkedin or
even site like stackoverflow does a
really good job of representing
developers of course if you're a
hackathon attendee maybe you'll be
assigned a teammate so that might be
just a serendipitous meeting of course
you can always go rummaging around in
cafes or coffee coffee shops and looking
for people with laptops as well okay and
how would I go about you know choosing
an engineer if I had you know 23 people
answer my craigslist ad how would I go
about choosing who I want to work with
choosing who you work with is a is a
something I think that's dependent on
what your end goal is if you're looking
for maybe a web based project then you
want to focus on a specific skill set so
you're looking for somebody with a
background in HTML CSS and JavaScript if
you're looking to go mobile full-fledged
mobile maybe native experience then
you're looking for somebody with iOS
development experience with Objective C
or Swift or even branching out into
Android as well you will need somebody
who has experience with that SDK and
with Java how would i go about working
with an engineer you know when i when i
found one that i want to work with how
do i go about actually asking them for
help how do i go about getting use out
of them sure from my perspective I like
to get involved as early in the project
lifecycle as I can getting me involved
means showing me a lot of the design
work that's happening explaining a lot
of your thinking as your as your feature
set is evolving through the design
process i am going to want to understand
what your end goals are i'm going to
want to understand what you believe is
the minimum viable product and i'm going
to want to understand what your
longer-term goals are for your project
right and so naturally you want to be
involved as early as possible now would
be the way to get the most use out of
you but there's also this pull of you
know if i'm isola entrepreneur might
have
limited budget I might not be able to
pay you for the entire life of the
project so in that case would it make
more sense to just take you on at the
end when I can actually you know just
ask you to build the app and that's all
I've got money for well you know the app
experience can be or bigoted or as big
or as small as you want to make it so
bringing me on at the end would be okay
but i think we lose a lot of the context
a lot of the decisions that are made
through the prototyping phase through
the design phases i think can inform
upon how the product is built so again i
would want to come on a little bit
earlier in the product life cycle now
that said if you do leave it towards the
end then you're going to want to have a
really well-defined spec a really
fleshed out idea of what you want built
and then you're going to want to be able
to talk to that engineer about the
budget you're going to want to talk
about the feature set that you're asking
them to build and then you're also going
to want to set some realistic delivery
dates right and of course one common
thing is if I'm an entrepreneur who
doesn't have a background in coding then
what's going to happen is I might set
these unrealistically you know it might
not occur to me that thing x is going to
take a lot longer to build and think why
and I might assume they're going to take
the same amount of time and said you
know give you these delivery dates that
are for this one totally doable and this
one way unrealistic yep and that's why i
like to getting engaged in the project
early on so that i can set some
realistic expectations as well i do
think that it's important to involve
your developers in that regard so that
we don't end up with something like
feature creep or scope creep within the
project is very easy to become quite
enamored with particular interaction or
a set of screens that maybe are not core
integral to the experience we believe in
launching and iterating so striving
towards that min viability and involving
the developer early on will help you
establish what that looks like and i
hope you craft a plan of execution
perfect thank you very much welcome